the jurogan experience this is one of
the things that they say
people that have been abducted i had
travis walton this guy
i've seen i've seen him i've watched his
bobblehead i've watched
it very compelling in his descriptions
of his uh
encounter with these uh beings but one
of the things that he was saying was
they were talking to him
but it wasn't with words like they they
they were
communicating with him and he understood
what they were saying but it wasn't
he they weren't saying things you know
like hey
travis why don't you relax because we're
here from planet
[ __ ] whatever it is the information
was flowing faster because it was like
boom right away
what i think you get it yes they were
they were explaining things to him in
some sort of a telepathic way
wow and it was mind-blowing to him and i
think that that's
probably the future of communication
just like
you can transmit information from phone
to phone
right you can call people they're
nowhere near you but you can talk to
them you can send a video to someone
it's going through the air
it's just data right it's just
information
do you think travis and bob lazar and
all these guys that
have extraordinary claim
believe what they are telling you
i don't know if what they believe is
true but what
do you think they believe what they are
telling you in a way that they're not
lying they're telling the truth
of what they're believing i can't tell
for certain but i believe
bob lazar i believe what he's saying is
true
i believe he's telling me now bob
he had one moment where he was passing
by a window and he said he saw something
that was small and these people were
standing over it and he doesn't know
he didn't know if it was uh an alien
or whether it was a uh like a
uh you know some sort of a
a form that they were trying like a doll
or something that's supposed to
represent the size of an alien or
some sort of a model of an alien but he
remembers
he looked briefly through a window and
he saw something small
he didn't see it move around didn't see
it talk so he doesn't know what he saw
because
in his world as he explained it when he
was working at area
area 51 site four that's where he worked
he said that
it was very compartmentalized and this
thing was one of the problems with them
trying to
figure out you know this is assuming
he's telling the truth yeah of course
one of the the problems they were trying
to figure out was
how to back engineer these devices these
these ships but the problem was they
weren't allowed to communicate
with other people outside of this very
limited group of people that had access
to these
these vehicles and the people that were
involved in the metallurgy were not
allowed to communicate with the people
that were involved
in um the uh whatever the propulsion
system was they didn't understand
what they proposed they were trying to
decipher these things but he said
and if you listen to the podcast that i
did with him that it didn't
it didn't work because the scientific
method requires
multiple people to communicate and share
ideas and to explain
and they didn't you can't improve like
that right you need to share ideas
you can't do something and
compartmentalize everything
but my communication with him i i
again i don't know if he was telling me
the truth but he didn't seem deceptive
and he's a brilliant guy when you yeah
it's clear he
is clearly like borderline genius you
hear him speak he's very educated
and the thing some of the things that he
talked about came to fruition like one
of the things was
there was a concept of this thing called
element 115
right now that was not really proven
until the 2000s or somewhere in the
2000s
they they'd use a particle collider and
created this thing
where it was a very unstable very
short-lived
particle but he was saying that
wherever these beings are from they have
figured out a way
to utilize a stable version of this
element 115
and that's how they propel themselves
the the things that he was describing
were also exactly the same things that
were experienced by commander david
fravor
who was a guy who is a jet pilot yeah
and so
he experienced this thing move in that
same direction that same way
where there was no visible propulsion
system but they track this thing going
from 80
000 feet above sea level to one in one
second
so that's the amount of time that it
takes radar to to
to track this so it might have been less
than a second this thing traveled
from 80 thousand feet to one time there
was no time for to one feet it's
like that thing in that with the hand he
says he measured the the the distance
between the bone and the
you know like uh when you get in you
know you put your hand in it and measure
the distance between your bone and the
oh the scanner yes there is a lot of
things like this you know like zachariah
sitchin
was you know like there's a lot of stuff
that you
you can think of that how could
they know that at the time but it's man
it's well the zacharias hitch and stuff
is interesting right that's all
the the sumerian text the sumerian text
is some fascinating stuff because
it's all from 6 000 years ago and by the
way zacharias hitchen
he's very controversial there's a
there's even a website called
sitchin is wrong dot com and it's
basically
scholars of ancient sumerian who say
that his translations are completely off
but even if his translations are off
there's still a lot of
really confusing stuff about ancient
sumer and one of the things is their
depictions
of the solar system they had a depiction
of the solar system
6 000 years ago that shows the sun in
the center
and it shows all of the known planets in
the outside
and they're you know they're they're
relatively
accurate in terms of the size yeah and
how about the formation of the hurt
tiamat marduk i don't remember which one
is what i
but i def you know that's yeah formation
of the earth
that's the model that we we use today
well the scientists
asteroid belts like that's the model
that that we we
use today how did he knew that at that
time i don't know how they knew that
when you're saying it's earth one and
earth two and what that means is that
there was an
an original version of earth and then
earth was hit
by another planet at some point in the
distant distant past
and that's what created the moon and
that's also what created the asteroid
belt that goes on the
different direction than the rest of the
the
the planet like they they knew that too
well there's also a thing called bodes
law
and bode's law measures the distance
between planets and it's based on the
mass of the planet
and they figure out because of the mass
of planet how far
these planets are from from each other
and one of the things that [ __ ] that up
is the asteroid belt
i think the the what i might be wrong
about this but
the the distance between mars and
jupiter
is uh one of the things that screws that
up and they think that's
explained by the asteroid belt that some
collision
created this asteroid belt and created
uh
all of the i mean there's something like
900
000 known near-earth objects that are
created by the impact of these planets
one thing i believe and i'm sure you're
the same because you had a lot of these
guys on your podcast
graham graham and cup randall carson um
john anthony west like yes there is
clearly knowledge that we've lost
yes in the past like this is
for sure like just think about the alex
library of alexandria yes
man imagine the knowledge that it wasn't
there before it burned
i know imagine oh man imagine people
thinks we lost like one
million millennia like just when it
burns out
of knowledge you know medicine botany
science it's just crazy to think of
so some very often sometimes when crazy
stuff happen like that like
i just think that perhaps they have
knowledge that
that there's knowledge that we lost like
just think about the greek fire
it's a weapon that was used in the naval
battle
and it's it's it's really really known
about historian
you can research they still don't know
exactly how it works but it was
so destructive it was like at that time
it was like a secret weapon like they
didn't want to share and it was known
to be very efficient and naval battle i
don't know what that is i don't know
about great
great fire if you go greek fire you'll
get it boom it
used to it was used in naval battle so
we used to throw
they used to troll fire flames and they
used to
people that got that they are burning
they still
burn in the water so they think it was
made with some
kinds of petrol or or they still don't
know
they don't they cannot recreate it and
it's clearly something that a lot of
historians have
talked about it's called greek fire
it's just an example that it's clear
that it's it's
technology that we have lost well if you
just look at the pyramids
the pyramids are a perfect example of
technology lost it's almost like the
best example
like like those ancient civilizations
almost
letting everyone know hey there is
information that we have that's so above
and beyond what's expected of people
from this era
because if you think about people that
lived 2500 bc
you don't think about someone that had
the kind of proficiency
to create something that when people
understand
it's not just that the pyramids were big
but they were so
perfectly designed that when they put
all the stones
they reached the top like if anyone was
off by even a half an inch at the bottom
as time went on an inch here an inch
there by the time they got to the top
it'll be all [ __ ] up
it wouldn't be perfect but the pyramids
were so amazingly perfect
and they were originally covered in
smooth limestone
so smooth polished limestone that would
probably be
insane to look at if you were staring at
it from a distance like this
immense structure of two million three
hundred thousand stones
some of them cut from quarries hundreds
of miles away
all perfectly aligned and put together
by these people that lived
thousands and thousands of years ago
you know that most scholar would say
that they use a ramp but if you think
about it
like there's other scholars that would
counter that by saying the
the construction of that ramp need to be
in an angle that
it could be so difficult to do that it
will
challenge the construction of the
pyramid itself you know again it's like
maybe they use a ramp i don't know what
they use
we don't know yeah but what whatever
they used
it's so amazingly precise
that they were able to make this 2
million 300
000 stone structure this still to this
day
i haven't been but i have friends that
have gone like
my friend andrew schultz just went uh
danica patrick the race car driver she
told me she just went
people that i know that have been my
friend eddie bravo when he went he's
like you're like you get there you're
like
what the [ __ ] it's so big apparently
second awakening yes that our our idea
of what it is
when you see it in a photograph it looks
incredible but i guess
i need to go because i guess when you
see it in person it's just a
like a complete reset like you it
recalibrates what people are capable of
because you have to think like man this
is this is four thousand
five hundred years old think about that
there and could you
go back litepe
like how can you how do you conceive
that and sometimes what happened is that
it get uh
you know and infected by it by pre by
other civilization that pass there after
that construction so they think
they are the one that built it i think
it's is it um
pumapunku the one that there's clearly
two different technology you see the
the stone are perfectly aligned with
like perfectly cut yeah then you have an
other stone that are just on top like it
like
it's like a butch butcher's job you know
and
it's clearly not the same technology the
same people that
build these two layers you know well
that's also john anthony west's
the concept of egypt that there's
multiple eras
and that the if you go deeper like some
of the stuff that they found when they
dig deeper in the sand was a different
construction method it looked different
different designs and but still equally
complex and
fascinating it's like there's probably
many errors of human civilization and
there's probably been
whatever it is whether it's disease or
some sort of a natural disaster or
something that happened
asteroidal impact was john anthony or
was randall carson's
and graham hancock's that's their theory
is that 12 000 years ago
at the end of the place this scene there
right yeah but homo sapiens
date to 3000 3000 years old yeah
you know for so imagine 3 000 no
i think it's older than that i think
it's several hundred three two three
three hundred thousand sorry yes
three three hundred thousand sorry my
english yeah oh right homo sapien is
three hundred thousand in morocco what
is this i'm 100
sure that's why i i read about this kind
of stuff
i think they think it's somewhere in
that neighborhood yeah yeah yeah but but
so if you take that 300 300 000 sorry
300 000 time to for an evolution
right why would it be only in the last
12 10 000
years that we would you know invent such
amazing
structures like it's kind of strange it
doesn't make sense
well it's also we're so different from
all the other animals like we're the
only animal that wears shoes we're the
only animal that wears clothes we're the
only animal that really manipulates its
environment the way we do i mean other
animals think you know
bees make beehives and [ __ ] like that
but they don't do anything
remotely interesting in comparison to
what we're capable of doing and what we
have done for thousands and thousands of
years and why
you know one of the things that bob
lazar said that he was taught when he
was
at area s4 at area 51 s4
was that one of the things that they
were telling him was that human beings
are the product of accelerated evolution
and that these creatures occasionally
come back to check upon our progress
and yeah which is crazy wow but but that
might be how it works throughout the
universe is that these
beings that are very far advanced they
come back and they
see these creatures that are pretty
close and they give them a little boost
they push push them ahead a little bit
because otherwise it would take so long
and maybe we don't have the amount of
time
because of the fact that we're in this
[ __ ] shooting gallery of asteroids
that these things come down and whatever
progress you make is wiped out
by impacts or by super volcanoes it's
crazy but it's not that crazy if you
look at
the belief of human being through
evolution you know like
in ancient greek they believe in
different they they were believing in
different gods they
like it in different times different
civilization had different belief now
some people believe jesus walk on water
you know
which is fine too that's their belief
you know if you believe
that human was you know the the the
result of
and like alien beings you know it's
another belief you know like it's not
everybody believe in different things
it's not that crazy
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre on your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience